where is funky stand-up funky hi Kelly
oh it's kind of weird I broke a world
record I broke the world record for most
signatures tattooed on one's back and
I've had a lot of people that inspire me
like Tony Hawk tattooed me steve-o Kevin
Hart
Wayne Brady Stanley I would I would
really like for your signature to be on
there oh my god wait you have all those
cool people why you want mine to mess it
up so many well there's one particular
reason but there's a lot of reasons
you're an American icon yeah first time
we're gonna have a winner so what's
happening now so basically I've signed
your body and you're gonna go to your
time yeah like a baby get it Caitlyn I'm
funny I know no I'll keep this and you
go get tattooed and we'll see you soon
all right I hope you don't regret it
let's go get this tattoo done
[Music]
what are we doing to this regular
Tuesday I'm gonna go get Kelly
Clarkson's tattooed
I mean signature tattooed on my back and
controlling with all the other ones and
in collaboration to the world record I'm
excited I started this project with like
five or six friends here in Los Angeles
actually and it was just supposed to be
friends and eventually it blew out of
control my first celebrity tattoo was I
think it was Tony Hawk Tony Hawk was the
first one that was in 2012 and it was
the first time he had ever tattooed
anyone also so which is cool hi I'm
Becky G tattoo I'm gonna be tattooing
Kelly Clarkson's signature the craziest
celeb tattoo I've done was probably the
tattoo I did last night it was a
flamingo
but as Tupac the Flamingo was throwing
up West Side had all Tupac tattoos had a
bandana it was it was awesome and that
was just last night so that's cool
[Music]
how many cookies do you have right now
225 and a half when she's done 226 I was
the first person to tattoo themselves
while skydiving I got this done with you
says fly it's been maybe like 10 years
since I started this so there's a lot of
stories a lot of stuff I think Stanley
probably the hardest on Stanley took
three days my manager talking to their
manager they didn't understand what was
happening they're like what do you mean
world-record tattoos what do you mean
and then eventually I just showed the
manager my bagging is like this is
awesome let's go awesome let's see what
happened here
[Music]
nice lines Thanks we're going back to
show Kelly it's going it's going it's
gonna go I want to see Kelly's face
all right funky
okay done with his tattoos [ __ ] you come
on out
music taking down he did not I chickened
out
you trained I did it I did it and the
crazy part was I walked in right and
River was there gonna tattoo my daughter
she will be if you're on the tabloids
I'll cut that piece out what's wrong
with us I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my YouTube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this